It's January, and for some people, that means the start of a month with no alcohol. Dry January, which began in the UK in 2013, has become increasingly popular in recent years. The trend may reflect a broader surge of interest in living a low or no alcohol life. Sales of non-alcoholic beer, wine, and spirits increased more than 40% between 2021 and 2023, and fancy mocktails and non-alcoholic beers are an increasingly common site on bar and restaurant menus in the U.S. So what's driving this cultural moment? Why are so many people interested in cutting back their alcohol use or giving it up entirely? And what are the effects on people's physical and mental health? Does taking part in dry January tend to change people's drinking
现在是一月份，对某些人来说，这意味着一个完全不喝酒的月份开始了。起源于2013年英国的“戒酒一月”活动，近年来变得越来越受欢迎。这一趋势可能反映出人们对过低酒精或无酒精生活的热情在整体高涨。无酒精啤酒、葡萄酒和烈酒的销量在2021年至2023年期间增长了40%以上，精致的无酒精鸡尾酒和无酒精啤酒在美国酒吧和餐馆的菜单上也越来越常见。那么，是什么推动了这一文化现象呢？为什么这么多人有兴趣减少或完全戒掉酒精？这对人们的身心健康有什么影响？参与“戒酒一月”是否会改变人们的饮酒
habits for the long term, or is it just a temporary change? And if you'd like to give Draw January a try, what advice do psychologists have to help you succeed? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Richard DeVisser, a professor of health psychology at Brighton and Sussex Medical School in the UK. His research interests span a range of topics in health psychology, including sexuality and relationships, gender and health, and alcohol use. Since 2013, he's been working with the group Alcohol Change
习惯并产生长期影响，还是只是一次临时的改变？如果你想尝试一下“戒酒一月”，心理学家有什么建议能帮你成功？欢迎收听《心理学说话》，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客节目，探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是英国布赖顿和苏塞克斯医学院健康心理学教授理查德·德维瑟博士。他的研究兴趣涵盖健康心理学的多个领域，包括性与人际关系、性别与健康以及饮酒行为。自2013年以来，他一直与“英国戒酒”组织合作，
UK, which originated the Dry January campaign to study the effects of taking a voluntary, temporary break from alcohol. He's the author of more than 130 scientific papers and has been interviewed by media outlets, including the BBC, the Washington Post, and the Wall Street Journal. Dr. DeViscer, thank you for joining me today. Thanks very much for having me on. Can you start by telling us about the history of dry January? Many people here in the US have heard of it and maybe even participated in it, but they don't know where it all started. So in the UK, dry January ran for the first time in 2013.
该组织发起了“戒酒一月”运动，旨在研究自愿、临时戒酒的效果。他是130多篇科学论文的作者，并接受过BBC、《华盛顿邮报》和《华尔街日报》等媒体的采访。德维瑟博士，非常感谢您今天能来。非常感谢邀请我。您能先给我们讲讲“戒酒一月”的历史吗？美国这里的许多人都听说过这个活动，甚至可能参与过，但他们不知道这一切是怎么开始的。所以在英国，“戒酒一月”在2013年首次举办。
And it was, as you mentioned in the introduction, it was run by Alcohol Change UK, which is a charity or a small NGO that's one of its missions is to change the conversation about alcohol. So they're not an abstinence-based organization. What they wanted to do was to think of a way in which they could help people to stop pores, think, about why, how and when they drink and maybe give them some support that if they wanted to take a short break from drinking, they could do that. So they set up this campaign and it changed quite a lot over the last 12 years now we're up to. Originally there was a website where people would sign up and they would get some supportive emails
正如你在引言中提到的，它是由“英国戒酒”组织运营的，这是一个慈善机构或小型非政府组织，其使命之一就是改变关于酒精的对话。所以他们不是一个基于禁欲的组织。他们想要做的是想出一种方法，帮助人们停下来、思考一下他们饮酒的原因、方式和时间，并可能为他们提供一些支持，如果他们想短暂戒酒的话，就可以做到这一点。因此他们发起了这项活动，在过去的12年里，它发生了很大的变化，现在我们已经迎来了第12个年头。最初有一个网站，人们可以在上面注册并获得一些支持性的电子邮件
and things like that. And over the years it's changed so that now there are various iterations and improvements of the Try Dry app, which can be downloaded for mobile or cell phone use. The content of that has changed. So it gives people supportive messages. It links into the website, so it allows people to chase up recipes and things like that. It allows people also to get the kind of messages that motivate them. And it reflects, as you mentioned, it reflects a broader kind of change.
诸如此类的内容。多年来，它发生了变化，现在有了“尝试戒酒”应用程序的各种版本和改进版，可以通过手机或智能手机下载。其内容也发生了变化。它为人们提供支持性的信息。它与网站相连，允许人们查找食谱之类的内容。它还允许人们获得那种能够激励他们的信息。正如你所提到的，它反映了一种更广泛的变化。
There's actually dry July, which runs in New Zealand and Australia, has been running for slightly longer. So same idea, but you do it in the southern winter, so it makes more sense. And there is other campaigns. There's a similar campaign in the Netherlands called ICPAS. In two French-speaking locations, they seem to have got it even better by making it a February challenge. So the Tony Mineral in Belgium and the Faruizure-Ju-Az al-Kor, which is run in parts of Canada, both run for 28 days in February. So that's not even easier, easier challenge than the other one. But the idea about the campaign is to get people in however that might work and for whatever
事实上，新西兰和澳大利亚也有“戒酒七月”活动，举办时间稍长一些。同样的理念，但你在南半球的冬天进行，这样更有意义。还有其他一些活动。荷兰有一个类似的活动叫ICPAS。在两个讲法语的地方，他们似乎做得更好，把它变成了二月挑战。比利时的Tony Mineral和加拿大部分地区举办的Faruizure-Ju-Az al-Kor都在二月份进行28天的挑战。所以这甚至是一个比另一个更容易完成的挑战。但这项活动的理念是让人们无论通过什么方式、出于什么
reasons and to try to support people to take a try month if they can, and also maybe to see if it does have a longer-term effect on their drinking. So how many people signed up to participate back in 2013 and how many are doing it now? Do we have any idea? Yeah, so these are the UK figures. There are around about 5,000 people in 2013. It steadily increased. After the first couple of years, it got a bit of publicity and there's a bit of support from a public health England, which was a government public health body.
原因都参与进来，并努力支持人们尝试过一个月的戒酒生活（如果他们做得到的话），同时也看看这是否会对他们的饮酒习惯产生更长期的影响。那么2013年有多少人注册参与，现在又有多少人在做呢？我们有什么概念吗？是的，这些是英国的数据。2013年大约有5000人。人数在稳步增长。在最初的几年之后，它获得了一些知名度，并得到了英国公共卫生局（一个政府公共卫生机构）的一些支持。
And then the numbers did increase, and then they realized that it kind of had a life of its own. So they kind of really stepped back and let things run. And now there's around about 150,000 people in the UK sign up every year. And lots of people will join in, you know, from other locations. That's one of the great things about, you know, where everything's available online now is that people can join from all over the place. But what we also know from parallel research is that general population studies show that around about 10 times as many people in the UK are trying to have a dry month. Maybe they're doing it under their own steam or maybe it's something that they just do anyway in January.
然后人数确实增加了，接着他们意识到这个活动有了自己的生命力。所以他们实际上退居幕后，让事情顺其自然地发展。现在英国每年大约有15万人在网上注册。还有很多人会从其他地方加入进来。现在一切都在网上获得，这是最棒的事情之一，人们可以从四面八方加入进来。但我们从平行研究中也了解到，一般人群研究表明，英国尝试戒酒一个月的总人数大约是这个数字的10倍。也许他们是靠自己的力量在做这件事，或者这本来就是他们在一月份会做的事情。
So what we kind of know now is that if you think of the adult population of the UK, maybe around about 50 million people, maybe about 70% of those are drinkers. and we've got maybe 1.5 million people trying to have a dry January. So it's had quite an impact. And it's interesting because over the years, when we first did this and we did some interviews with participants and people would say, I told my friends and they said, oh, dry January, what's that? And they said the whole thing would turn into some kind of discussion around. What's dry January?
所以我们现在了解到的是，如果你考虑到英国的成年人口，大约有5000万人，其中大约70%的人喝酒。我们大约有150万人试图度过一个“戒酒一月”。所以它产生了相当大的影响。这很有趣，因为多年来，当我们刚开始这样做并对参与者进行一些采访时，人们会说，我告诉我的朋友们，他们说，哦，“戒酒一月”，那是什么？他们说整件事都会变成某种关于……的讨论。什么是“戒酒一月”？
Why are you doing it? You know, what can I do to try to make you fall off the wagon before the end of the month? It seems as a bit of a challenge. And these days, people come along and they say, I'm doing dry January. And someone says, oh, you too, tell me something new that I haven't heard about before. It's really established itself in the kind of social media calendar, I guess. And that's one of the things about doing it in January. It is a time when people might say, I'm going to try to drink less, start the year with good
你为什么要这么做？你知道，我能做些什么来让你在月底之前破戒呢？这似乎成了一个小小的挑战。而现在，人们走过来会说，我在过“戒酒一月”。然后有人会说，哦，你也是，告诉我一些我以前没听说过的新鲜事吧。我想，它确实已经在社交媒体日历中确立了自己的地位。这也是在一月份进行这项活动的原因之一。这是一个人们可能会说“我要少喝点酒，以好习惯开启新一年”的时间，
intentions. This is a way of helping people to do that. So instead of people just saying, you know, I'm going to exercise more and then just leave them to it, this is saying, I'm going to try not to drink. Well, you can sign up, you can get some support. You can get some tailored support for you. There's also the sense of doing it as part of a group, which is also really important. So instead of it's, instead of it's you versus alcohol in the world, it's you with a whole lot of other people.
这也是帮助人们做到这一点的一种方式。因此，人们不是只说“我要多锻炼”然后就放任不管，而是说“我要试着不喝酒”。你可以注册，你可以获得一些支持。你可以获得为你量身定制的支持。作为群体的一部分来做这件事也有一种感觉，这也是非常重要的。因此，它不再是你与酒精和世界的对抗，而是你与一大群人在一起，
who are also trying to give up. And there's lots of mutual support seems to be really beneficial for the success of individuals, but also for the success of the campaign. In the UK, you've got quite an ingrained pub culture. Do you get pushback from that part of the populace? I think less so now than originally. And part of it is because I think of what you mentioned in the intro about the broader availability of non-apholic products and the fact that a lot of the large alcohol and spirit producers have recognized that, and they're now marketing to that, the different markets. So they realize that their market includes not only drinkers,
大家也都在努力戒酒。许多相互支持似乎对个人的成功非常有益，对活动的成功也同样如此。在英国，你们有着根深蒂固的酒吧文化。你们会遭到来自那部分民众的抵制吗？我想现在比最初要少一些了。部分原因我认为正如你在引言中提到的，无酒精产品的普及程度更高了，而且许多大型酒精和烈酒生产商已经认识到了这一点，他们现在正在针对不同的市场进行营销。所以他们意识到他们的市场不仅包括饮酒者，
but it includes non-drinkers and temporary abstainers. In the first few years, there was a lot of resistance from all of the pubs. They were saying, and restaurants generally as well, they were kind of saying, well, January is already really difficult. People aren't going out so much. They've spent all their money over Christmas. It's a lean time of the year, and you're going to make it harder for us. And I think also, for a lot of drinkers, it was difficult because
还包括不饮酒者和暂时戒酒者。在头几年，所有的酒吧都有很大的抵制情绪。他们和餐馆通常也会说，一月份本来就很艰难。人们不怎么出门了。他们在圣诞节把钱都花光了。这是一年中手头紧的时候，你们还要让我们雪上加霜。而且我认为，对许多饮酒者来说也很艰难，因为
they maybe didn't have the satisfying alternative to alcohol. So people might think, well, if I go out somewhere and I'm going to be charged the same amount for soft drink because I might be for alcohol and maybe everyone else is drinking, it's not going to make a difference, maybe it's a bit. But now people go out and they think, well, actually, there's a good no alcohol beer or I can get that nice cocktail or I've learned from my friends or from the dry January community what drink I can make at home that kind of scratches the itchita. So, yeah.
他们可能没有对酒精的满意替代品。所以人们可能会想，如果我出去某个地方，无酒精饮料收取的费用和酒精饮料一样多，而且可能其他人都在喝酒，这没什么区别，也许有点儿。但现在人们出去会想，实际上，有一种很好的无酒精啤酒，或者我可以买到那杯不错的鸡尾酒，或者我从朋友或“戒酒一月”社区那里了解到我可以在家做什么饮料来解解馋。所以，是的。
So you mentioned a moment ago. motivation. What motivates people to try this? What are the reasons that people give for joining in? Yeah, there are a lot of motives that people highlight. For a lot of people, they just want to have a reset in some ways. They think maybe December's been a bit too moist, and they think that, or it's been, you know, steeped in alcohol, and they think maybe it's a good time to have a break. So it might be, a lot of times, as people say, they just want to have a break. They may use terms like detox, for example, they realize that having a bit of time without alcohol might be good for their physiology. Sometimes people think, actually, I drink a lot and I drink in these different
所以你刚才提到了动机。是什么驱使人们尝试这个？人们加入的理由是什么？是的，人们强调的动机有很多。对许多人来说，他们在某些方面只是想做一次重置。他们认为十二月可能过得有点太湿润了，他们认为，或者说，这充满了酒精，他们认为这可能是一个休息的好时机。所以这可能是，很多时候正如人们所说，他们只是想休息一下。他们可能会使用诸如排毒之类的术语，例如，他们意识到花一点时间不喝酒可能对他们的生理机能有益。有时人们会想，实际上我喝了很多酒，而且我在这些不同的情况下喝酒。
situations. Maybe I just want to learn how to say no to a drink or how to say no to the temptation in those kind of situations. Sometimes people would do it because they want to raise money, so some of these challenges you can do it as a sponsored kind of event, and some of them run largely that's the motivation. And people might do it for the kind of associated health reasons. They might do it to lose weight, for example. And now a lot of people do it because of evidence of the other benefits, the psychological benefits that we've found from some of the research as well. So we've found that people who do take part do report things like Better Sleep.
也许我只是想学习如何在这些情况下对一杯酒说不，或者对诱惑说不。有时人们这样做是因为他们想筹集资金，所以其中一些挑战你可以作为一种赞助活动来做，其中一些主要是为了这个动机而运行的。人们也可能出于相关的健康原因这样做。例如，他们可能会为了减肥而这样做。现在很多人这样做是因为有证据表明其他好处，也就是我们在一些研究中发现的心理益处。因此我们发现，参与其中的人确实报告了诸如更好的睡眠之类的好处。
They feel that they've got better concentration, popular, because they're linked into Better Sleep. A lot of them say they save money, many of them lose weight as well. So these are majority experiences that people who take part. So around about half, so they lose weight, around about 60% or so, so they save money. It's up into the 70% of people who say that they sleep. better or have better concentration.
他们觉得自己有了更好的注意力，很受欢迎，因为这与更好的睡眠息息相关。许多人说他们省了钱，许多人也减了肥。所以这些是参与者的主要体验。因此，大约有一半人说他们减肥了，大约60%左右的人说他们省了钱。多达70%的人说他们睡得更好或注意力更集中。
And what's good is having that evidence from sound research is that's then used to feedback to encourage people to take part. If you take part, it might feel like you're giving up something. But these are the things you'll get pretty soon after. And I may be getting ahead of myself, but that's one of the things which helps to explain why a lot of people carry on with the reduced alcohol intake afterwards because they've experienced personally and bodily and psychologically some of these benefits which are much more immediate and recognizable than maybe advice from physician about your liver's going to look
好的是，有了来自可靠研究的证据，这些证据随后被用来反馈并鼓励人们参与。如果你参与其中，可能会感觉你放弃了某些东西。但这些是你很快就会得到的东西。我可能有点操之过急了，但这也是帮助解释为什么许多人事后继续减少酒精摄入的原因之一，因为他们亲自、在身体上和心理上体验到了一些好处，这些好处比医生关于你的肝脏在40年后会看起来糟糕透顶的建议要直接得多，也更容易识别。
terrible in 40 years down the line. What we know from psychology and kind of learning and training and shape and behaving lots of there is if there's immediate and repeated feedback, it's much more likely to have an effect than if it's really delayed towards the end. So people, it's not to say that people don't find it difficult to start with, but pretty soon after stopping, they start to recognize some of these effects. And the things that don't cost them any money, they cost a bit of effort. but people are sometimes surprised at how much better they feel. And that can encourage them to keep on going. And another point I should say,
我们从心理学以及学习、训练和塑造行为中学到的一点是，如果有直接且重复的反馈，它比那种拖到最后才给出的反馈更有可能产生效果。所以人们并不是说一开始不觉得困难，但在停止饮酒后不久，他们就开始认识到其中一些影响。这些事情不花他们什么钱，只需要花一点精力，但人们有时会惊讶于自己感觉好多了。这可以鼓励他们坚持下去。我还要指出另一点，
so going back to the initial question you asked is around about one in six of the participants that completed surveys at least say that they're doing this because they want to completely give up alcohol. So they use this supported month as a way of kick-starting that, of developing the skills, have finally set something in motion, which they then want to carry on with.
回到你最初的问题，完成问卷的参与者中大约有六分之一表示他们这样做是因为他们想完全戒酒。所以他们把这个有支持的月份作为启动这一过程的一种方式，用来培养技能，最终将某件事情付诸行动，然后他们希望继续坚持下去。
So there's a real range of motivations. And do they report back, over time as to whether they have continued to abstain? Yeah, so we've done studies. The longest we've been able to manage is a six-month follow-up. So the typical design of the research that we've done has been to get people right at the end of December just before the challenge starts,
所以动机真的很广泛。随着时间的推移，他们会反馈自己是否继续戒酒吗？是的，我们做过研究。我们能做到的最长时间是六个月的跟进。所以我们所做研究的典型设计是，在十二月底挑战开始前正好抓取参与者，
then to come back to people in the first week of February and then to come back in August, so six months down the track. And there's a real drop-off in participation because people just, they're not thinking about it anymore. We send them emails and they're just not interested. it. But there are a number of people who say that they, so we know from the surveys, we asked people whether they've taken part before and we asked them in which years. There are a number of people who come back every year and do this. It's almost like the yearly
然后在二月的第一周再次回访人们，接着在八月份也就是六个月后再次回访。参与度出现了明显的下降，因为人们只是不再去想它了。我们给他们发电子邮件，而他们根本不感兴趣。但有相当一部分人表示他们，所以我们从问卷中得知，我们询问人们以前是否参与过，并询问他们在哪些年份参与过。有相当一部分人每年都回来做这件事。这几乎就像是一次年度
reset. But there are plenty of people, there's plenty of anecdotal reports of people that say, well, I started off like this. I did it for a month. I thought, well, let's see if I can make it to the end of February. And then Easter's coming and they say, well, I normally give up something for Lent, for example. Or they don't. But they think maybe I can give up something for Lent. And suddenly it's suddenly the idea of abstaining and this challenge is something they can complete. is apparent to them. It's something that wasn't maybe there before, so they keep going. And then it's the thing. Then people make it through the summer and they think, okay, I keep on going. And before they know it, a year's rolled around. But there's been less attention
重置。但也有很多人，有很多关于人们的轶事报道说，嗯，我就是这样开始的。我做了一个月。我想，好吧，看看我能不能坚持到二月底。然后复活节就要来了，他们说，嗯，我通常会在四旬斋期间放弃某些东西，例如。或者他们没有。但他们认为也许我可以在四旬斋期间放弃某些东西。突然之间，戒酒的想法和这个他们可以完成的挑战对他们来说变得显而易见了。这是以前可能不存在的事情，所以他们继续坚持下去。然后就是这样。接着人们度过了夏天，他们心想，好吧，我继续坚持下去。在他们意识到之前，一年已经过去了。但关注度已经降低了
that's been given to that from our side of things and from the arc or change perspective, because that's not really a main kind of motivation. It's not about a kind of full-time abstance kind of campaign. So there's less evidence, less hard evidence on the long, long-term effects in terms of an abstinence kind of focus thing. But we know that a lot of people do start off for that motivation and we know that a lot of people cut back in their drinking, so they're drinking less when that comes to August. So you mentioned people reporting that they sleep better, for example. Are there other mental and physical health changes that they report after a month of abstaining from alcohol? Yeah. So there's the sleep that I mentioned. People report having
这是我们和“酒精意识或变革”组织从自身角度赋予它的，因为这并不是一种主要的动机。这不是那种全天候戒酒的活动。因此，关于长期戒酒效果的硬核证据相对较少。但我们知道，很多人最初确实是出于这个动机开始的，我们也知道很多人在八月份减少了饮酒量，所以他们到那时喝得更少了。比如你提到有人报告说睡眠变好了。在戒酒一个月后，他们还报告了哪些其他的心理和身体健康变化？是的。正如我刚才提到的睡眠。人们报告说
more energy and better concentration. And these are things where we just, we tend to use a fairly simple self-report measures. I mean, there's questions about the validity of these measures, but what we're doing within subjects, you know, pre-post kind of measure over time is at least we can assume that unless there's systematic variation in people's reporting, that might be, because this might be a bit technical, but because we ask people to use the same standard measure and we're only comparing them against themselves, any change, the extent to which it reflects real change is questionable, but we find maybe the simplest thing to say is that people say the sleep is better, they feel like their brain is working better because they're concentrating,
精力更充沛，注意力更集中。这些通常是我们采用相当简单的自我报告测量方法的领域。我的意思是，这些测量方法的有效性确实存在疑问，但我们在受试者内部所做的（你知道的，随着时间推移的前后对照测量）至少可以让我们假设，除非人们的报告中存在系统性偏差——这可能有点技术性，但因为我们要求人们使用相同的标准测量方法，并且只将他们与自己进行比较，任何变化（即它反映真实变化的程度）都是值得商榷的，但最简单的说法可能是，人们说他们的睡眠变好了，他们觉得自己的大脑运转得更好，因为他们的注意力
trading better, they have more energy. There are those things about weight loss as well. There are other studies, not these are studies not ones that we've done, but by other people have done these physiological studies where they will take smaller groups of people and will do blood tests, for example, and measure different parameters. And so they measure things like after a month without alcohol, levels of liver fat, and blood cholesterol and blood sugar are reduced as well. So there are noticeable physiological and psychological effects that come from just a month, not trying to keep. No one goes to Hank's for his spreadsheets.
更集中了，精力也更充沛了。还有关于减肥的一些情况。还有其他研究，不是我们做的，而是其他人做的生理学研究，他们会招募较小规模的群体进行血液测试等，并测量不同的参数。因此，他们会测量戒酒一个月后，肝脏脂肪、血液胆固醇和血糖水平也会降低等指标。因此，仅仅一个月不饮酒，就能带来显着的生理和心理效果。没有人会去汉克斯那里看他的电子表格。
They go for a darn good pizza. Lately, though, the shop's been quiet. So Hank decides to bring back the $1 slice. He asks co-pilot in Microsoft Excel to look at his sales and costs. Help him see if he can afford it. Co-pilot shows Hank where the money's going and which little extras make the dollar slice work. Now, Hanks has a line out the door. Hank makes the pizza.
他们是去吃美味绝伦的披萨的。不过最近，店里变得很冷清。于是汉克斯决定重新推出一美元一块的披萨。他请微软Excel中的Copilot查看他的销售额和成本。帮他看看自己是否负担得起。Copilot向汉克斯展示了资金的去向，以及究竟是哪些小添头让一美元披萨的方案得以行通。现在，汉克斯店门口排起了长队。汉克斯负责做披萨。
Co-Pilot handles the spreadsheets. Learn more at M365. have copilot.com slash work. Is there any kind of a rebound effect for some people where after dry January is over, they get back to drinking with a vengeance in February? There's some evidence that happens for some people. And I should say, I guess the caveat as well is to say that there's a message that goes to people when they sign up.
Copilot负责处理电子表格。访问M365.have copilot.com slash work了解更多。对于某些人来说，是否存在某种反弹效应，即在“干燥一月”结束后，他们在二月份以更猛烈的势头重新开始饮酒？确实有一些证据表明这种情况会在某些人身上发生。我应该说，我想需要说明的一个前提是，当人们注册时，会收到一条信息。
And this is one of the things I think is important about signing up and the value of that is if people come in and they're thinking they're quite heavy drinkers and they think that this is going to be the way in which they can control their alcohol consumption, the given message is that they should actually be looking for something else and ideally kind of supported assistance to withdraw from alcohol because what would be not advised by anyone really for anyone who's addicted or dependent on alcohol would be to say just try by yourself if you can get yourself off the alcohol we know that's not going to be successful approach we find that some people around about 10% of people report drinking more after dry January and that tends to
我认为这是注册的重要意义和价值之一，如果人们来参加时，认为自己是重度饮酒者，并且认为这将是他们控制酒精摄入量的方式，那么得到的信息是，他们实际上应该寻找其他方法，理想情况下是有支持的戒酒协助，因为对于任何对酒精成瘾或依赖的人来说，真正不会被任何人建议的做法就是“如果你能戒酒，就自己试着戒掉吧”。我们知道这不是一个成功的方法。我们发现大约10%的人报告说在“干燥一月”后饮酒量反而增加了，而这往往
be it's much more likely to be the people who try to make it through the month and don't to make it through. And that is also more likely among people who are the heavier drinkers to start with. So it does, not surprisingly, it's a more difficult challenge for the heavier drinkers. They're the ones who are less likely to make it through the month. And the people who don't make it through the month are the ones who are more likely to report some kind of rebound effect. But it's still a majority. It's only about 10% of the sample that does that. Around about half of the sample goes back to drinking pretty much as they were before. But they also feel more in control of their drinking. And they've got these skills to resist
更有可能发生在那些试图坚持一个月却最终没有坚持下来的人身上。这在最初属于重度饮酒者的人群中也更为常见。因此，毫无意外，这对重度饮酒者来说是一个更具挑战性的考验。他们是更不可能坚持满一个月的人。而那些没有坚持满一个月的人，更有可能报告某种反弹效应。但这依然只是少数。样本中只有大约10%的人会这样。大约有一半的样本在活动结束后恢复了活动前的饮酒状态。但他们同时也觉得对饮酒有了更多掌控感。他们掌握了抗拒这种诱惑的技能
that, well, they understand their alcohol consumption a bit more. And the other roughly 40% of people drink less at the six-month kind of period. And that's a combination of drinking on fewer days per week and or drinking less on the days when they do drink. So they're either deciding to have more dry days rather than a dry month, or they're having slightly drier drinking days as well when they're doing that. What about people who just intentionally drink wines or beers with a lower percentage of alcohol, is that participating in what I've heard called a dampish January? There's lots of different ways to think about reducing alcohol consumption. So obviously, doing a dry January is quite a drastic change for people because it means not
或者说，他们对自己的酒精消耗有了更多的了解。另外大约40%的人在六个月的周期内饮酒量有所减少。这是每周饮酒天数减少和/或每次饮酒量减少的结合。因此，他们要么决定增加无酒精日而不是单单过一个无酒精月，要么在饮酒的日子里也稍微少喝一点。那么，那些故意只喝酒精含量较低的葡萄酒或啤酒的人呢？这算不算是我听说过的所谓“温和一月”？关于减少酒精摄入量，有很多不同的思考方式。显然，进行“干燥一月”对人们来说是一个相当剧烈的改变，因为这意味着不
drinking and it may also require socializing in different locations, which aren't alcohol-infused kind of areas. So some people think that what might be better for them is doing a two-week, I have a really good friend who he and his partner do a 10 dry days in January every January. They get through Christmas, they have a bit of kind of catch up the things. And then in the middle of January, when they've got no money, their friends haven't anyway, they'll do this. And that's, I mean, it does tie into that idea about when is an easy time to do it? When's an easy time to think about maybe drinking a bit less?
饮酒，这可能还需要在不同的社交场所进行，而这些场所并非充满酒精的区域。因此，一些人认为，对他们来说更好的可能是进行两周的尝试。我有一个非常好的朋友，他和伴侣在每年的一月份都会进行为期10天的无酒精日。他们度过了圣诞节，稍微聚会庆祝了一下。然后在1月中旬，当他们手头没钱的时候（反正他们的朋友也没钱），他们就会这么做。我的意思是，这确实契合了这样一个观点：什么时候是进行这件事的轻松时机？什么时候是考虑稍微少喝一点酒的好时机？
So people could do that. People could do a shorter, adstander period. Or people might say things like, I'm going to drink on fewer days per week. So I won't drink during the week, but I'll only drink on the weekend. that can be one way to cut things back. That's fine if it works for someone. People might say, I still like to drink because I like to have a glass of something with my lunch, with my dinner, or when I'm watching a film or sport or whatever it might be.
所以人们可以这样做。人们可以进行一个较短的、戒酒的时期。或者人们可能会说：“我将减少每周的饮酒天数。所以我周不喝酒，只在周末喝。”这可以成为减少饮酒量的一种方法。如果这对某人有效，那就很好。人们可能会说：“我仍然喜欢喝酒，因为我喜欢在吃午饭、晚饭时，或者看电影、体育比赛等任何时候，喝上一小杯。”
And in those cases, someone drinking a 0.5% beer instead of a 5% beer or drinking a low alcohol wine instead of a 12% alcohol wine, that's another way to reduce the alcohol intake. And I guess the thing that sits behind a lot of this stuff is you know, there's increasing evidence that the safest and healthiest amount of alcohol to consume is probably none, and anything above that is can be harmful. So any way that people can find that works for them to reduce their alcohol intake is fine, I think.
在这些情况下，一个人喝0.5%酒精度数的啤酒代替5%酒精度数的啤酒，或者喝低酒精含量的葡萄酒代替12%酒精含量的葡萄酒，这是减少酒精摄入量的另一种方法。我想，这一切背后的核心是：越来越多的证据表明，最安全、最健康的酒精消费量可能是零，任何高于这个量的摄入都可能是有害的。因此，我认为只要人们能找到适合自己的方法来减少酒精摄入量，那就是好的。
Dry January isn't for everyone. It's not designed to be, and a lot of people might find it difficult, but if they can find another way to reduce their alcohol consumption or feel like they're more in control of their drinking, then they could try that. And if it works for them, then, you know, nobody loses in that situation. I've heard you say that trying dry January is not a good idea for people who have an alcohol use disorder or physical dependence on alcohol. Why is that? And for those people, what should they be doing in January or at other times? Yeah. I mean, if people know that they are
“干燥一月”并不适合所有人。它也不是为此设计的，很多人可能会觉得很难，但如果他们能找到另一种方法来减少酒精摄入量，或者觉得自己更能掌控饮酒了，那么他们就可以尝试那种方法。如果对他们有效，那么你知道的，在这种情况下没有人是输家。我听你说过，对于有酒精使用障碍或对酒精有身体依赖的人来说，尝试“干燥一月”并不是一个好主意。这是为什么呢？对于这些人来说，他们在1月份或其他时间应该做什么？是的。我的意思是，如果人们知道自己
or suspect that they might have an alcohol dependence or addiction, I mean, the thing they should really do is to seek professional help to, one, first of all, some kind of assessment of their, of their drinking, what the health effects might be as well, because sometimes they may be unaware of the health impact is having. So getting some of the information through whether that's, you know, blood tests or whatever it might be, could be there. But talking to a health professional about that would be a starting point that's there. The reason why it would be not advised for someone to try an unsupported attempt at kind of just cutting out alcohol completely would be that the problems with one about managing some of the physical effects of withdrawal, some of the psychological
或者怀疑自己可能存在酒精依赖或成瘾，我的意思是，他们真正应该做的是寻求专业帮助，首先对他们的饮酒情况以及可能产生的健康影响进行某种评估，因为有时他们可能没有意识到酒精对健康的影响。因此，通过诸如血液检查或其他任何方式获取一些信息可能会有所帮助。但与健康专家讨论此事将是一个起点。为什么不建议某人在没有支持的情况下尝试完全戒酒？因为这里存在一些问题：一方面是应对戒酒的一些身体反应，另一方面是心理
effects as well. And I think in those cases, and what we know from some other contexts as well, is if people try to do that and find it very difficult, the likelihood that they will then return to drinking and potentially drinking in harmful ways. And also psychologically, you're feeling like, well, I can't do it. There is no hope for me. That can be reinforced and that's not a great way to start. So some people need more support and help than others to make these changes. And for people who are drinking a bit less or already feel a bit more in control of their drinking, something like tri-gary might work because it's about building on the confidence and the kind of skills that they already have. For people who are starting off from a point where
反应。我认为在这些情况下，从其他一些经验中我们也能了解到，如果人们试图这样做却发现非常困难，那么他们随后重新开始饮酒并在潜在有害的方式下饮酒的可能性就会增加。此外，在心理上，你会觉得：“好吧，我做不到。我没有希望了。”这种心态会得到强化，而这并不是一个好的开端。因此，与其他人相比，有些人需要更多的支持和帮助来做出这些改变。对于那些饮酒量稍有减少或已经觉得更能掌控自己饮酒的人来说，像“干燥一月”这样的活动可能会奏效，因为这建立在他们已有的自信和技能基础之上。而对于那些从起点开始就
they already feel like they're not in control of their drinking and they're having trouble already managing their alcohol consumption or they're already negative effects of alcohol consumption, it probably makes sense for them to talk to someone else about what they could do, what the alternatives might be, and not to try an unsupported attempt to detox effectively. We wouldn't recommend that for any other addictive substance. We wouldn't say to anyone, girlfriend, just try by yourself. Don't come to me or don't get my advice beforehand. In those situations, you've got to think about making sure that someone knows what the potential
已经觉得自己无法控制饮酒、在管理酒精消耗方面已经遇到麻烦，或者酒精消耗已经产生负面影响的人来说，找别人谈谈他们可以做些什么、有哪些替代方案，而不是尝试进行一次没有支持的戒毒，这可能更明智。对于任何其他成瘾物质，我们都不会建议这样做。我们不会对任何人说：“亲爱的，自己试试吧。不要来找我，也不要事先征求我的意见。”在这些情况下，你必须考虑确保有人了解潜在的
benefits might be, but also consequences could be of an unsuccessful attempt and why that support is really helpful. And it may mean as well, there may need to be some kind of pharmacological help to deal with some of the withdrawal symptoms and manage those kind of unpleasant kind of aspects of withdrawal for those people who are heavy drinkers. Do you have any advice or tips for people who are trying to do dry January? You mentioned apps or there are other like supportive things out there that people can access that will help them get through the month? Definitely. I think, as I said before, I think we have about, you know, maybe for every person who registers officially for dry January, there's maybe 10 times as many people who were doing an unofficial dry January. And that's just in the UK. What we found in one study we did recently where we looked at those had signed up for dry January compared them to other people who were trying to cut down their alcohol intake through other ways during January. And what we found was that people who signed up for dry January were twice as likely to make it through the month without drinking than those who just tried by themselves. So registering official. does seem to increase the likelihood that someone will make it through the month.
好处可能是什么，但也要考虑到不成功的尝试可能会带来什么后果，以及为什么这种支持真的很重要。对于那些重度饮酒者，这可能还意味着需要某种药物治疗来应对一些戒酒症状，并管理那些令人不快的戒酒方面。对于那些正试图进行“干燥一月”的人，你有什么建议或小贴士吗？你提到过应用程序，或者市面上还有其他人们可以使用的支持性事物，能帮助他们度过这个月吗？当然。我认为，正如我之前所说，我觉得，比如说，对于每个正式注册参加“干燥一月”的人来说，可能大约有十倍的人在进行非正式的“干燥一月”。这仅在英国就是如此。我们在最近的一项研究中发现，我们将那些报名参加“干燥一月”的人与通过其他方式在1月尝试减少酒精摄入量的其他人进行了对比。
And that has benefits one just because psychologically it would probably feel a lot of better to an individual to say, yes, I made it through the month. But also the people who make it through the month without drinking feel more in control of their drinking. They experience more of the health and psychological benefits and they're more likely to be cutting down the drinking later on. So registering officially is quite useful because it means that you tie into then a whole network of support.
我们发现，报名参加“干燥一月”的人在戒酒满一个月方面的成功率是不自己尝试的人的两倍。因此，进行正式注册似乎确实能提高一个人坚持满一个月的可能性。这样做有一个好处：单从心理上讲，对个人来说，说一句“是的，我坚持了一个月”会感觉好得多；其次，没有喝酒而坚持满一个月的人会觉得对饮酒更有掌控力，他们能体验到更多的健康和心理益处，并且更有可能在后期继续减少饮酒量。因此，正式注册非常有用，因为这意味着你接入了一个完整的支持网络。
There's the information that comes through emails and through the app and those kind things. There's also the sense of belonging to a kind of community that's there and the community to support that's available seems to be really important. People share recipes for alternative drinks. People also share stories about how they manage difficult situations or what they say to their friends who are pushing them or nudging them to have a drink and those kind of things. Another benefit that comes from it is this, when people do register, they can sign up to get emails or get regular prompts through the app as well. So every day you might, or every week, or depending on how frequently you want them,
有通过电子邮件和应用程序发送的信息以及诸种类的事物。还有一种属于某个特定社群的归属感，而这种可用的社群支持似乎非常重要。人们分享无酒精饮品的食谱。人们还分享他们如何应对困难情况的故事，或者他们对那些敦促或怂恿他们喝一杯的朋友说些什么，诸如此类。另一个好处是，当人们注册时，他们可以报名接收电子邮件，或者通过应用程序定期收到提示信息。所以每天你可能，或者每周，或者取决于你希望的频率，
you can get a message of support from them. It might say, well done, you've made it through another day. What's also changed over the years is instead of the feedback, just being about how much alcohol people haven't drunk, is people can now choose which kind of messages they want to get. It could be how many drinks they've not had compared to usual, but it could be how much money they've saved or how many calories they've not consumed.
你可以收到一条支持信息。它可能会说：“干得好，你又坚持了一天。”多年来发生的变化是，反馈不再仅仅关乎人们戒掉了多少酒，人们现在还可以选择他们想收到哪类信息。它可以是与平时相比他们少喝了多少杯酒，也可以是他们省下了多少钱，或者他们减少了多少卡路里摄入。
And depending on what motivates people when they're coming into this, are they thinking about saving money, losing weight, or just feeling more in control. those messages can be tailored to meet the motivational or the motives that will best influence that person. So again, it's like in a lot of different areas. If we can find out what motivates the individual and give them feedback that ties into those motives, it's much more likely that that will seem relevant. So people can choose how frequently and what kind of messages they want to get to support them.
根据人们参与时的动机是什么——他们是在考虑省钱、减肥，还是仅仅为了获得更多掌控感——这些信息都可以进行定制，以迎合最能影响那个人的动机。因此，这再次类似于许多不同的领域：如果我们能找出是什么在激励个人，并向他们提供契合这些动机的反馈，那么这些反馈就会显得更有相关性。因此，人们可以自主选择他们希望收到什么频率和什么类别的消息来支持自己。
So there's, and what we've found, to go back to the point, what we found is that people who make more use of the support are much more likely to make it through the month than people who don't who just try it by themselves. And what about developing a circle of friends who will go into dry January with you? Is that something that you recommend? Does that work better? I think it's one of those things that varies a little bit. I mean, we've looked at that.
因此，正如我们所发现的（回到刚才的观点），我们发现充分利用支持的人比那些不使用支持、只靠自己硬撑的人更有可能坚持满一个月。那么，培养一个和你一起进行“干燥一月”的朋友圈呢？这是你推荐的做法吗？这样效果会更好吗？我认为这是那种因人而异的事情。我的意思是，我们对此进行过研究。
We've looked at how many, a lot of people do sign up with someone else. It could be a work colleague or a family member or a friend. That seems to be less important than some of the other things like using the supports available. But for some people that can be quite important. So we look across the board. It might be the case that there are people who really would only, do it if it was with someone else. If that's what gets them started, then that's great to go for them. There's, you know, there's not any need to do that. We don't have any really strong evidence
我们研究过有多少人与其他人一起报名。这可能是一个同事、家庭成员或朋友。这似乎比利用可用的支持等其他因素显得不那么重要。但对某些人来说，这可能相当重要。所以我们从整体来看，可能会有这样的人：他们真的只有在和别人一起的情况下才会去做这件事。如果这是让他们开始的动力，那对他们来说就太棒了。并没有必要非得这样做，我们并没有任何强有力的证据
that it makes it much more likely. But of course, I guess the issue there is that you might have some people who do it without a buddy, I guess, a non-drinking buddy who don't want to. And there are some people who maybe would benefit from that support but aren't able to get it. So it's a little bit difficult because, you know, you also can't have, it's difficult thing to measure properly because we don't know how many of the people are doing it solo. We'd like to have a buddy that they're doing it with as well. So it's, but that can be one thing. If people think that, that would help them, then that's probably worth trying. If they do that, as well as signing up to the website or using the app as well, they're getting the best of all worlds,
表明这会大大提高成功率。但当然，我认为这里的问题在于：有些人可能没有伴侣一起做（我是指非饮酒的同伴）而不想做，而有些人可能本可以从这种支持中受益，却无法获得它。因此这有点难以处理，因为你知道，这也无法进行妥善的衡量，因为我们不知道有多少人在独自完成的同时，也希望能有一个同伴一起做。所以，这可能会有一点影响。如果人们认为这能帮到他们，那么这或许值得一试。如果他们在注册网站或使用应用程序的同时也这样做了，他们就可谓是占尽了所有的优势，
because they're getting their support and whatever, the motivation from the, because it could also be the motivation not to be the person who caves in or gives in. And we find that in other areas as well. I know that, say, in the UK, the National Health Service, Stop Smoking Services, have a range of things. Some are individualized and some are group and some are buddy systems. And it's really about thinking about what works for each individual. If I were a smoker, I'm not. But if I were a smoker, the idea about going to a stop smoking group would be something I've run away from. I'd much rather try it out by myself. But there are a lot of people who'd say, I couldn't do it unless I were doing it with other people. And so it's important to think about, you know, and that's why I think that the content, but also the range of different formats of support has really changed. That's one-a-jointed over the years with dry January, just recognizing there are a lot of people who come into this
因为他们得到了支持等等，动力来自于——因为这也可能是为了避免成为那个妥协或让步的人的动力。我们在其他领域也发现了这一点。我知道，比方说，在英国，国民保健制度（National Health Service）的戒烟服务提供了一系列措施。有些是个性化的，有些是小组形式的，还有一些是伙伴系统。这其实就是在思考什么对每个人最有效。如果我是一个烟民——我不是，但如果我是，去戒烟小组这种事是我会避之不及的。我宁愿自己一个人尝试。但也有很多人会说：“如果不是和别人一起做，我根本做不到。”所以，思考这些问题很重要，这也是为什么我认为内容以及各种不同形式的支持确实发生了变化。这些年来，随着“戒酒一月”（Dry January）活动的开展，人们逐渐意识到有很多人参与进来，
for a lot of different reasons. And rather than trying a one-size-fits-all approach, people can tailor to some extent what they're doing. So a long way around of getting to your question about doing it with someone else is, it really depends. If people think that it might help them, you can give it a try. And if not, there's no kind of sense that they'll be missing out necessarily if they don't do it, buddy.
原因有很多。人们不是采用一种“一刀切”的方法，而是在某种程度上可以根据自己的情况进行调整。所以，兜了这么大一个圈子来回答你关于和别人一起做的问题，答案是：这真的要因人而异。如果人们认为这可能对他们有帮助，就可以尝试一下；如果没有帮助，也并不意味着如果不找伙伴就会错过什么。
Now, since dry January started, are you seeing a decrease in alcohol consumption overall in the UK? Yeah, I mean, it's difficult to say what causes what and what's part of the broader kind of change. I think at the broader level, I think the idea about having, you know, a dry month or something like that has spread a bit more broadly. And there are things, there are other campaigns, other parallel things. So I also do some work with meat-free Mondays, which is a charity aim to, you know, kind of reduce meat consumption. They do it by having one meat-free day per week rather than the month.
那么，自从“戒酒一月”活动开始以来，你看到英国整体的酒精消费量在下降吗？是的，我的意思是，很难说究竟是什么导致了什么，以及什么属于更广泛变革的一部分。我认为在更广泛的层面，拥有一个“戒酒月”或类似的概念已经传播得更广了。还有其他一些活动，其他平行的活动。所以我也参与了“无肉星期一”（meat-free Mondays）的工作，这是一个旨在减少肉类消费的慈善机构。他们通过每周实行一天无肉日而不是整整一个月来实现这一点。
There is a campaign that runs here called Vigannuary, which runs in January, which is trying to give up meat in the month as well. So I think there's more of a sense, more of an awareness of maybe a slightly more questioning kind of view about things that were previously seen as been quite alternative and small, you know, minority kind of interest or activities like not eating meat or not drinking. They're not perceived as being so unusual now. And I think there's also there are these kind of positive feedback loops in a way and that the more people start talking about it, the more people will start trying it out.
这里还有一个名为“纯素一月”（Veganuary）的活动，在1月份举行，也是试图在这个月里不吃肉。所以我认为，人们有了更多的意识，对那些以前被视为相当另类、小众的兴趣或活动——比如不吃肉或不喝酒——可能会抱有一种稍微带点质疑的看法。现在，这些行为不再被认为那么不寻常了。我认为这也存在某种积极的反馈循环，越是有人开始谈论它，就会有越多的人开始尝试。
The more people try it out. People talk about it more. And then people talk about it not being kind of ways which are. isn't that odd, but it's kind of like, oh, there's another person that's like that. And I think the kind of contextual landscape, the consumer landscape, has changed as well. So 13 years ago, 12 years ago, if you were doing dry January, there would be fewer alternatives for you to have in terms of places to go and products to buy or drinks to make it home. And now there are dry bars, there are mocktails made in lots of different places.
越多的人尝试，大家就谈论得越多。然后人们谈论它时不再觉得“这不是很奇怪吗”，而是会觉得“哦，又有一个人是这样的”。而且我认为消费者的语境和景观也发生了变化。所以在13年前、12年前，如果你在过“戒酒一月”，你可以选择的替代品会比较少，无论是去的地方、购买的产品还是在家调制的饮品。而现在有了无酒精酒吧，很多地方都能买到无酒精鸡尾酒（mocktails）。
You know, you see it not just in dry January, but you see it through the year now. They'll be on the board. There'll be, you know, we try this mocktail. or whatever it might be. So it's not contained to that time or space or those unusual people over there. It's like anyone could do this at any time. And you see a similar thing with the dietary kind of things as well. You know, 10, 15 years ago, it might be, okay, what's the one vegetarian option on the menu?
你知道，你不仅在“戒酒一月”期间能看到这一点，现在全年都能看到。它们会出现在菜单板上，会有诸如“尝试一下这款无酒精鸡尾酒”之类的推荐。所以它不仅限于那个时间、那个空间或那些不同寻常的人。这就好像任何人随时都可以这样做。你在饮食方面也能看到类似的情况。你知道，10到15年前，菜单上可能只有一个素食选项，
And now you see lots of different things. And we see it more broadly in the UK as well. There are a few young people who are drinking, you know, in the US and other similar cultures. There are those changes. There are fewer people drinking alcohol in the same way. There are few people who are eating meat. well, there are more people who are reducing their meat consumption at least. And at the same time, the producers and marketers of these products have realized that if they don't,
而现在你能看到各种各样的选择。我们在英国更广泛地看到了这一点。有一些年轻人正在减少饮酒，在美国和其他类似文化中也是如此。这些变化正在发生。减少饮酒的人变少了……不对，是喝酒的人变少了，吃肉的人也变少了。嗯，至少有更多的人在减少肉类消费。与此同时，这些产品的生产者和营销人员意识到，如果他们不
you know, literally and metaphorically cater to those needs, they're going to be missing out on some kind of slice of the market. So like I said, there's that positive feedback loop, I think, whereas more people do it, so there are the products that are available and because the products are available, more people think that it's a feasible alternative and so on. You have these kind of positive feedback loops, I guess. Is anybody looking at those products? I mean, I know a lot of them, there are many, many more on the market now,
字面和隐喻意义上迎合这些需求，他们就会错失一部分市场份额。所以就像我说的，这里存在一个积极的反馈循环：因为更多的人参与，所以有相应的产；因为产品随手可得，更多的人认为这是一个可行的替代方案，诸如此类。我想你会有这种积极的反馈循环。有没有人在研究这些产品？我的意思是，我知道其中很多产品，现在市面上有非常非常多，
originally like non-alcohol beer was disgusting, but now there's a lot of non-alcoholic beer that taste pretty good. And I'm just wondering, do we know what's in these products? So sure, you're not consuming alcohol anymore, but you're consuming something else. I'm not too sure about that, about the content of the products. I mean, I think it is the thing. It's often you see similar things with, you know, sugar-free products. And people think, well, what is the alternative for sugar? Is that longer term, is it better to eat the sugar or not? Or what's the alternative to eating dairy butter compared to some other synthetic kind of product. That's not an area of expertise.
最初非酒精啤酒很难喝，但现在有很多无酒精啤酒味道相当不错。我只是在想，我们知道这些产品里面有什么吗？当然，你不再摄入酒精了，但你在摄入其他东西。我对这一点——产品的成分——并不是很确定。我的意思是，我认为情况就是这样。你在无糖产品上经常也会看到类似的情况。人们会想，糖的替代品是什么？从长远来看，吃糖更好还是不吃更好？或者与某些其他合成产品相比，吃乳制品黄油的替代品是什么？这不是我的专业领域。
I don't know. That's one of the things. That makes me think whether they've got time within the next, between now and the next survey we're doing to put a question in asking people about, are they concerned about or are they thinking about the content of the other products? Now, is there other research you're doing in the area of alcohol consumption and what are the questions that you would like to answer? I guess there are two big groups we've got.
我不知道。这是其中的一点。这让我想到，在下一次我们正在做的调查到来之前，他们是否有时间在其中加入一个问题，询问人们是否关注或考虑其他产品的成分？现在，你在酒精消费领域还在做其他什么研究？你希望回答哪些问题？我想我们有两大类群体。
One is the people are interested in changing their behavior. already. Well, they're motivated to change, but they don't know how to do it. And what they need is the support and advice to carry on with that. How many people will start and try certain things and then maybe go back to where they were and come forward? What are the processes of change? And within that, what are the identity change processes that happen there as well? When does someone stop identifying as a drinker, for example, or when do they call themselves something else? When does someone change their definition of themselves? And it does tie in a little bit to some of the stuff you think about some other abstinence programs as well about people defining at the start of the
一类是对改变自己行为已经感兴趣的人。他们有改变的动力，但不知道该怎么做。他们需要的是支持和建议来继续坚持下去。有多少人会开始并尝试某些事情，然后可能又回到原点，接着再前进？改变的过程是什么？其中又发生了什么样的身份认同改变过程？例如，一个人什么时候不再把自己定义为饮酒者，或者什么时候他们称呼自己为其他身份？一个人什么时候会改变对自己的定义？这确实与你所考虑的一些其他禁欲项目有一定联系，即人们在
behavior change process. They define themselves in a certain way, either as an identity they're trying to move away from. So if you take the 12-step kind of things about saying, I am an alcoholic, and so I therefore have to do things differently. So the identity is really fixed as an alcoholic, and they behave in certain ways to either to recognize that and say, therefore, I have to do these things so I don't engage in alcoholic behaviors. Or you could do something else which is saying, I'm a non-drinker, even before you've given up completely. But the aspirational identity is the non-drinker. So you use that as the target to move towards. And this goes right back to your cognitive dissonant stuff as well, is about if you define yourself in a certain way and the ideal self that
行为改变过程开始时对自己的定义。他们以某种方式定义自己，要么是试图摆脱的一种身份。如果你采取12步戒酒法那种说法，即“我是一个酗酒者，因此我必须采取不同的做法”。所以身份非常固定为一个酗酒者，他们的行为方式要么是为了认识到这一点并说“因此我必须做这些事情，这样我才不会从事酗酒行为”。或者你可以做另一件事，那就是说“我是一个不喝酒的人”，甚至在你完全戒酒之前。但这种抱负性的身份就是“不喝酒的人”。所以你把它作为努力的目标。这其实也追溯到了你的认知失调相关的内容，即如果你以某种方式定义自己，并且你向其他人投射的理想自我
you're projecting towards other people is something is a particular version of yourself and you're not quite there, two things could happen. You change the identity, but you've just said that that's valuable. So the other alternatives, you change the behavior and the lifestyle so that matches that identity as well. So I think it's goal setting, isn't it? And thinking about steps that are there and how can we find ways that work for different people at different steps along the way. The second group of people is the people who aren't currently motivated to change their behavior and thinking about what would it be that would motivate them to change their behaviors. How do we get the I'm quite happily drinking too much people into, oh, maybe I'm drinking too much, maybe I need to
是特定版本的自己，而你还没有完全达到那个状态，可能会发生两件事：你改变了身份，但你刚刚说过那个身份是有价值的。所以另一个选择是，你改变行为和生活方式，使其与该身份相匹配。所以我觉得这就是设定目标，对不对？思考各个阶段的步骤，以及我们如何能够找到适合不同阶段不同人群的方法。第二类人是目前没有动力改变行为的人，我们需要思考是什么会激励他们改变行为。我们如何把那些“我挺高兴地喝着过量酒精”的人转变成“哦，也许我喝得太多了，也许我需要
do something about that. And that may be a little bit more difficult because a lot of the timeframes of the different alternatives are kind of quite different, you know, yes, there may be some kind of benefit in the future from changing my drinking behavior, but right now I quite enjoy it and it's an important part of my social life and I live in a culture where drinking happens. The cost to me personally and socially might be too great. So how can we use that kind of information? And I think what we've, going back to the dry January thing, I think what we've kind of found which has been useful is rather than giving the messages which are the long-term health effects is to say, actually,
做点什么”的状态。这可能会稍微困难一些，因为各种替代方案的时间框架截然不同，你知道的，是的，改变我的饮酒行为未来可能会有一些好处，但现在我挺享受的，而且这是我社交生活的重要组成部分，我生活在一个饮酒盛行的文化中。对我个人和社交造成的代价可能太大了。那么我们如何利用这些信息呢？我想我们所发现的——回到“戒酒一月”这件事上——我们发现有用的是，与其给出那些长远健康影响的信息，不如说：其实，
you may not believe it, but you'll actually feel better quite soon and in quite a range of different ways if you try something, why not give it a try. And even if you go back to drinking, drinking a bit less, then that's a benefit that's come from that. And I think the thing that's interesting about that is that it is that embodied experiential kind of learning that has a much stronger motivating effect than the prospect of better health, which also lies alongside the prospect of worse social life. That's what people might see. So it's a really difficult way to think about what motivates people, what would motivate them to change their behavior, and how can we've identified the things that would really help them, we're encouraging to
你可能不信，但如果你尝试一下，你实际上会在相当短的时间内，以各种不同的方式感觉更好，为什么不尝试一下呢？即使你后来又开始喝酒了，少喝一点也是从中获得的好处。我认为有趣的地方在于，这种具身的、体验式的学习比“未来更健康”的前景具有更强烈的激励作用，而“未来更健康”的前景同时也伴随着“社交生活变糟”的前景。这可能是人们所看到的。所以，思考是什么激励人们、什么能激励他们改变行为，以及一旦我们确定了真正能帮助他们的事物后，如何鼓励他们
take that first step that might let them see something different. To close a personal question, do you abstain in January? No comment, no. No, I guess. Not in general. I have done a dry month before. So after first doing the research, the first time I contacted I called Change UK. So the backstory to this is that I constantly.
迈出可能让他们看到不同事物的第一步，是一件非常困难的事情。作为一个私人问题，你在1月戒酒吗？无可奉告，不。不，我想不会。总的来说没有。我以前确实度过一个无酒精月。所以在最初做完研究之后，我第一次联系了“改变英国”（Alcohol Change UK）。这背后的故事是，我不断地
contact them in 2013 when it was first running saying, are you doing any evaluation of this? And they said, well, we're a small organization. We don't have the resources for that. And I said, well, I can do something, you know, small and small scale, first of all, but using the resources I have, if you can, if you're able to send links to online surveys to people, we can do that quite easily. And then that was the start of what turned into a very productive relationship and mutually beneficial. And when we started off, it was interesting because the person who started up, Emily Robinson, who's no longer there, she was doing something earlier where she was being sponsored by people to train and run a marathon. And there's a
在2013年刚开始举办时联系他们，问：“你们有对这个活动进行评估吗？”他们说：“我们是一个小型组织，没有这方面的资源。”我说：“好吧，我可以做一些小规模的事情，首先使用我手头的资源，如果你能把在线调查的链接发给人们，我们可以非常轻松地完成。”然后，这就开启了一段后来变得非常富有成效且互利共赢的关系。当我们刚开始时，情况很有趣，因为发起人艾米丽·鲁宾逊（Emily Robinson）——她现在已经不在那里了——她早期在做一件事，当时她通过赞助来训练并跑马拉松，这是一种
fundraising thing, as often happens. And she thought, this is strange. I really like running. Why are people sponsoring to do something I enjoy? They should be sponsoring for something that would be really difficult. And then she was thinking, well, you could do this thing, and maybe she'd heard of Dry July, maybe you could do something like that. But she hadn't done it either. It was really interesting. So every year, we chat about these things, and she'd say, that's already awkward because you have these events or you have these meetings and people say, oh, how's your dry January going? And she'd have to kind of say, oh, no, don't worry about me. How's yours going? How's dry January? I said, oh, it's really busy. It's really good. Are you trying to
筹款活动，就像经常发生的那样。她觉得这很奇怪：“我真的很喜欢跑步，为什么人们要赞助我去进行我喜欢的事情？他们应该赞助那些真的很困难的事情。”然后她一直在想，你可以做这样一件事，也许她听说过“戒酒七月”（Dry July），也许你可以做类似的事情。但她自己其实也没做过。这真的很有趣。所以每年我们都会聊起这些事情，她会说：“这已经很尴尬了，因为你参加这些活动或开会时，人们会问‘你的戒酒一月进展如何？’然后她不得不说‘哦，不，不用管我，你进展得怎么样？戒酒一月过得怎么样？’我说‘哦，非常忙，非常好。你是不是想
flip things? But having those, I thought, okay, at least need to try it and do it. So I have twice I've done dry months at different times of the year. And it is interesting then to do it kind of almost in secret, like not saying to people, this is what's happening, not having that kind of thing. Because a lot of people also say dry January, it's great because I can say to people, on doing this change, but it's only for January. You know, and people's friends as well say, oh, great. So we'll have you back in February then. We'll get the real new back in February.
把事情反转过来？”但有几次这样的经历后，我想，好吧，我至少需要尝试去做一次。所以我曾经在一年中的不同时期两次度过戒酒月。然后几乎以秘密的方式去做这件事真的很有趣，比如不告诉别人正在发生什么，没有那种大张旗鼓的架势。因为很多人也说“戒酒一月”太棒了，因为我可以告诉别人：“我在做这个改变，但这只持续到一月。”你知道的，朋友们也会说：“太好了，那我们二月份再见啦。二月份我们会迎来真正的那个新版你。”
So I'm not doing dry January, maybe next year. All right. Well, Dr. DeViscer, I want to thank you for talking to me today. This has been really interesting. Thanks very much. And enjoy the rest of your dry or not so dry January. Thank you. You can read more about psychologists' research on dry January
所以我要么不做“戒酒一月”，也许明年再说。好的。德维斯（DeVisser）博士，非常感谢你今天与我交谈。这真的非常有趣。非常感谢。祝你剩下的时间——无论是戒酒还是不戒酒的“戒酒一月”——都过得愉快。谢谢。你可以阅读更多关于心理学家对“戒酒一月”研究的内容，
in the January issue of APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology. go to www. APA.org slash monitor. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And for those of you who want to know more about psychology and the work of APA, you can join us as a supporter. You don't have to be a psychologist.
刊登在APA杂志《心理学观察》（Monitor on Psychology）的一月号上。访问 www.APA.org/monitor。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在苹果、声田、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的平台上找到往期的《心理学访谈》（Speaking of Psychology）节目。对于那些想要更多了解心理学和 APA 工作的人，你可以加入我们成为支持者。你不需要成为一名心理学家。
The benefits include a subscription to our award-winning magazine Monitor on psychology, as well as discounts on our books and other publications. So if psychology is your passion or if you just want to know more about the science, you can become a supporter by visiting at. AT.APA.org slash speaking. That's att.a.org slash speaking. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mill. sales. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
福利包括订阅我们屡获殊荣的杂志《心理学观察》，以及购买我们的书籍和其他出版物时的折扣。所以，如果心理学是你的热情所在，或者你只是想了解更多关于这门科学的知识，你可以通过访问 at.APA.org/speaking 来成为支持者。网址是 at.APA.org/speaking。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以通过 speakingofpsychology@APA.org 给我们发电子邮件。《心理学访谈》由李·温纳曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。感谢收听美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的节目，我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。